Steve wants to talk today a little bit
about about morality I wanted to say a
few things because some about vulgar
morality and wait for meaning this
afternoon I'm one of these people who
fine the morality question that baffling
actual date at all and when I you know
I'm asked how can we possibly ground
morality my answer is we we've been
doing it we've been doing it very well
and what the thing that has really
impressed me about morality is uh we're
actually it is a place where philosophy
has made a difference that there is room
for reason and there is a kind of
forward movement in morality we look
back in absolute horror at things that
our ancestors did we look back in
absolute heart and some of the things
that we did in earlier life that we
found I've had quite a few men some of
them even in this room say to me you
know
Kant when I was a young man I just took
it for granted that women cannot do math
and and physics and you know name names
you know and I think that our great
grandchildren will look back at her and
some of the things that we do and then
one of the interesting things is that
once something is look it's is seen with
horror
we never go back once slavery is
abolished a country never reinstituted
slavery there was one reversal that's
when Napoleon came in he did in the in
the colonies bring a slavery back for a
very short time but that's the only
reversal that's forward movement that I
can say so there is a place for and if
you actually look back you see
philosophers actually making the first
arguments when nobody's talking about it
and that's you know something happens
you know people write novels you know
Uncle Tom's Cabin huge huge effect but
you know it started with John Locke in
the 17th century making an argument
about about slavery our very good
argument saying look if we're already
committed to this then on things of
inconsistency we have to be we have to
widen our notion of what creatures are
treated with with dignity and it's so
there is a place for reason here and for
for for moral reason um given the
background in evolutionary psychology
but there is you know there's something
going on in evolutionary psychology the
other thing I just want to say is
evolutionary thought you know it's not
enough I've been interested by the work
of jonathan haidt i do for the
conclusions that he draws from it but
it's an interesting the different kinds
of morality all of which lie different
notions of morality different sentiments
of morality all of which lie we can give
evolutionary explanations for
yes well well let me just the five you
know the five moral sources of moral
different kinds of Moral Sentiments one
of them is derived from our
evolutionarily explained feelings of
disgust you know there are good reasons
for disgust I was very amused by that
review of Lincoln's book you sent me
thank you very much but we have a good
evolutionary you know that basically our
disgust is is provoked by things that
the carriers of pathogens
this gets generalized we derive notions
of bodily purity from it I was brought
up to moralize certain foods you know
that I had a moral revulsion when I know
I went to the supermarket I saw sure
unadulterated lard a hunk of lard and I
was a moral revulsion you know that it
was it was so impure I've been talked
out of that uh there are there group
group what is loyalty that people feel
that a lot of Moral Sentiments come from
that again we can explain that a lot of
very things that one we can judge quiet
immoral come from that xenophobia we're
really trained to deal with about a
hundred and fifty thousand if you feel
close to 150,000 people tops that's the
size of a tribe 250 did I say 150 think
about girls not doing that
[Laughter]
what else
authority
you know Halloween Authority equality
and heart some of these things we can
actually rationalize I would say so that
you no harm to others fairness there are
arguments for this the other ones
there's no way to really argue them and
the end you can't argue that right and
so you know and they crumble
well they do for a good evolutionary
explanation but you know once the the
truth is moral psychology without moral
philosophy is insufficient and so you
know moral psychology will give you
these five and you need moral philosophy
to come in and say looks and some of
them are bogus and some of them can be
can be justified so that's that's my
little spiel about morality and I think
that in fact the law the second law
gives us since it gives us everything
and all sorts of asymmetry it actually
gives us in a way morale it gives us
mattering because one thing that
everybody knows and all behavior is
predicated on is that I matter
and you know I'm strategizing for my
future that's what some of the
strategies work and some of them don't
and when they work my genes get get
passed on but I am convinced and I don't
need any argument it's just a given you
know that I matter
and that's a place where moral reasoning
can can latch on and expand Salo if you
met or you know either your cosmically
unique in this universe or there are
some other creatures that matter as well
and you can you can get going and that's
how we've been doing it so that's my
flesh feel so Steve well I agree with
Rebecca
that you can usefully reason about
morality and we do but I think there's a
narrower question which is what
compelled me to volunteer to say a few
things which is whether we can ground
morality through science or any rational
process that is if you ask about moral
postulates principles from which you can
derive all your other moral judgments is
it possible to find such moral
postulates by reasoning from things
outside morality like science or the
theory of evolution or whatever
I'm impelled to raise this question by
being thoroughly annoyed by sam harris
book in which he claims science can
provide a basis for moral postulates I
don't believe it there's a long
honorable tradition of people who denied
this I think David Hume is the obvious
example and I don't think I have to
argue the case because the burden of
proof is surely on the other side those
who think you can ground moral
postulates in science or any other
rationale brought the thought processes
I I think have the burden of proof to to
do it and I don't think anyone has ever
successfully done so I don't think
Rebecca attempted to and the piece that
I read on the plane coming here she
showed how you can evoke moral feelings
by saying well I care about myself so
shouldn't I care about other people but
it you know one possible answer is no
and there's no rational process that
excludes that it seems to me
on the other hand as I said I think
there is room for reason in this area
because you might think that whether or
not you can ground them in science or
something like science that you actually
have Morrow postulates and you could try
to figure out what they are you can go
beyond that and say well perhaps we all
agree on our Marro postulates and then
it really isn't important whether we can
ground them in science I mean if
everyone except crazy people and
Psychopaths have the same moral
postulates and that would be wonderful
to find out even if you didn't know
where they came from
you could say well that should be the
basis of our system of justice or our
laws and our economic system and so on
that would be great what I want to argue
is that that doesn't work either that
not only can you not ground moral
postulates in science but in fact even
people who you would normally think of
as behaving in a moral fashion people
who are guided by a moral sense nice
people and for example me you not in
fact have a coherent set of moral
postulates and don't really need them
now there let me take a few examples of
this in high school I was very pleased
with myself for having decided that the
fundamental principle that governs our
actions should be the greatest happiness
for the greatest number I didn't know
that other people had gotten there ahead
of me and I was very chagrin to discover
the people like Mill and bedlam and said
something like this but it still seemed
to me almost self-evident that that's
right
I don't think in fact
that is the way I and I'm now going
public li going through a sort of
self-examination which I think we all
can do and we can do both individually
and collectively
I was disabused of this by reading a
novel brave new world by Aldous Huxley
he describes a society in which everyone
is happy except one misfit and everyone
is happy because they're conditioned to
be the alphas who run things are happy
because they're amused with sports and
sex and drugs and the other people who
have to do the menial work of society
are have their brains before birth
reduced in capacity so that they don't
want to be alphas who have to think hard
but they're just happy street sweeping
the streets and so everyone is happy but
you know it's it's intended to be a
ghastly world and it is it's a world in
which you have sex without passion and
entertainment without culture and
happiness without justice so you realize
no I'm not a I'm not a what is the word
I'm sorry yeah yeah I
that's not my moral postulate now Sam
Harris is aware of of this kind of
counter argument and says well it's not
happiness it's human welfare well as you
make things vaguer and vaguer of course
it becomes harder and harder to say that
it doesn't fit your own moral feelings
but it also becomes less and less useful
as a means of making moral judgments you
could take that to the extreme and say
it's
make up some nonsense word to say that's
the important thing and no one no one
could refute it but it wouldn't be very
helpful I regard human welfare in the
way Sam Parris refers to it us of
halfway in the direction toward absolute
nonsense but there are other things that
people would say well it may be that you
can't postulate what is the good that we
hope there are competing things which
are all good like happiness and truth
for example we sacrifice some happiness
when we accept the truth that we're not
going to have life after death should we
tell other people that they're not going
to live after they die it probably will
reduce their happiness on the other hand
truth has a value of its own how do you
balance truth and happiness
there isn't any algorithm for balancing
that I think you just have to accept
that there's no postulate which allows
you to judge how much happiness you're
willing to give up for so much truth
even people who accept all this will say
all right we're we're not going to agree
on what is the good but at least we can
agree on the fundamental principle of
morality that something like Rawls
original condition that we should not
treat other people worse than we treat
ourselves Rebekah was saying something
like this that everyone equally deserves
whatever is good happiness or whatever
it is that's not the way I feel either
and I think it's probably not the way
most of you feel if you think about it
because I could probably increase the
total amount of happiness by making my
family live on rice and beans and live
in a one-room apartment
and just barely keep enough money to
keep us alive and healthy and send all
the rest of the money to poor parts of
the world where we'd do a lot more good
than it does for me I'm not going to do
that I'm not going to do an act well I'm
not confessing immorality I'm saying
that my moral feelings tell me I should
be loyal to my family
similarly when my university tries to
recruit a bright young star in physics I
I suppose I could calculate well he
would really do more good for some other
university and the the greater good
would imply we shouldn't go after him
let some other university go after him I
don't care I I care about my university
I'm loyal to my University similarly am
I so their loyalty is a value it's not
an absolute value I wouldn't sacrifice I
wouldn't cause like Edward the third I
wouldn't cause the 100 Years War in
order to advance the interests of my
family but it's one of these things that
where we have no algorithm for balancing
loyalty against distributive justice and
I think we have to live with that I
think we have to live with the fact that
although we can reason and try to
uncover what our moral feelings are and
if we get into that I think a very good
example would be arguing about abortion
maybe I'll come back to that in the
discussion we can we can reason the
reasoning uncovers how we feel morally
and perhaps allows us to identify areas
of agreement so that we can cooperate
with each other and bring about what we
want I think in the end we have to live
with not having a moral philosophy that
really works in a decisive way
I think we have to live the unexamined
life I think this is part of the tragedy
of the human condition just like we have
no absolute way of determining that
Mozart is better than Led Zeppelin we
feel it but it's not something that we
can we can argue we can rationally show
we have to live with the fact that this
came up yesterday that when we discover
the fundamental laws of physics from
which everything in some sense thought
all other principles follow
we won't know why they're true it this
is something that we have to accept that
the position of human beings is tragic
and part of the tragedy is that there is
no way of deciding moral issues on on
the basis of well there is no way of
deciding moral postulates which should
govern our actions and in fact I don't
think we have moral postulates which
govern our actions even when we behave
morally
you